bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi à 15
décembre
paris saclay tête de gondole de la
candidature française pour l'exposition
universelle de 2025 jeudi tous les
acteurs du dossier étaient réunis sur le
plateau de paris saclay le territoire
sera haute du village global en cas de
victoire française retards à répétition
problèmes de circulation durant
plusieurs jours la situation dans les
transports en commun en ile de france
fait la une de l'actualité en ce moment
pour en parler nous recevons dans cette
émission armes smit membre notamment de
l'association des usagers des transports
franciliens
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
retour sous sur l'ouverture d'un salon
de coiffure solidaire à elancourt ou
encore une opération à rire pour guérir
en cadeau de noël pour les enfants de
l'hôpital du chesnay après la coupe du
monde 2023 les jeux olympiques en 2024
la france va-t-elle accueillir
l'exposition universelle en 2025
le comité expo france en tout cas à
présenter la candidature du site de
paris saclay hier soir à l'école
centrale supélec basée à gif-sur-yvette
la france et son site central seront
candidats notamment face au japon à la
russie et à l'azerbaïdjan
reportage de nicolas landry la
connaissance à partager la planète à
protéger c'est le thème de la
candidature française pour l'exposition
universelle de 2025
un projet porté sur le site de paris
saclay le village global serait installé
sur le campus composé de 65 mille
étudiants et 15 mille chercheurs avec ce
globe terrestre comme coeur de
l'exposition universelle
le visiteur sera appelé à faire vraiment
le tour du monde c'est à parcourir le
globe découvrir le monde et découvrir
également tous les enjeux de la planète
le projet d'aménagement
de toute cette zone correspond très bien
à ce croisement entre eux la science le
savoir le progrès d'un côté et puis
d'autres côté l'environnement la planète
dont nous savons qu'elle est pas mal en
danger 40 millions de visiteurs attendus
pour organiser cet événement expo france
2025 table sur un budget de 3 5
milliards d'euros financé en partie par
des entreprises pour les riverains les
avis sont mitigés
montrez au monde de savoir faire
français toute l'innovation
tu peux être rassemblées en un point
donc je pense que oui c'est une occasion
unique de briller
je vois ces photos ça me fait peur et ça
ne donne pas du tout envie ça paraît
sympa sauf que je vois l'impact
géographique en surface sur un endroit
qui qui était autrefois très agricole
avec des chants des bois etc
et je me dis que c'est l'occasion de
finir de le détruire
engagé dans la campagne michel bournat
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de paris saclay se veut
rassurant par rapport aux inquiétudes et
aux interrogations des habitants sur le
fait que pendant six mois s'il ya 40
millions de visiteurs
territoire risquent d'être un petit peu
surchargé c'est vrai c'est réel mais est
ce que c'est
utile ou pas pour notre territoire moi
je dis oui
le comité expo france 2025 va se lancer
dans la campagne internationale pour
tenter de convaincre les cent soixante
dix états membres
le vote final pour l'attribution de
l'exposition universelle de 2025 aura
lieu en novembre 2018 on passe à notre
invité fil rouge armes ce mythe est
d'ailleurs cet invité pour pour cette
émission bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
membre de plusieurs associations et
notamment du collectif au yen à saclay
un groupe de réflexion de concertation
sur le territoire de paris saclay qui
regroupe 120 associations c'est un hymne
à un groupe assez on va dire importance
sérieux l'exposition universelle 2025
qui aura lieu en partie sur votre
territoire pour vous déjà qu'est ce que
vous en passez penser ce que c'est un
facteur des développements importants ce
que vous êtes pour
est ce que vous êtes contre je ne suis
pas contre le principe d'une expo ni
lundi ni vercel mais sur le lieu où il
est projeté
ça va poser un sérieux problème
transport pour acheminer 60 ou 50
millions enfin selon le jour c'est quand
il s'était millions en tout cas sans me
dire que c'est des millions de personnes
qui viendront enfin le calcul que ça
fait deux cent à trois cent mille
personnes par jour est un peu acheminés
tout ça il faut grosso modo la capacité
du rer a
c'est à dire 60 75 mille personnes à
l'heure ce qui veut dire que la ligne 18
qui va arriver sur le plateau paris
saclay là on est à l'horizon 2024 ne
suffira pas en tout cas pour le temps de
l'exposition universelle il faudrait
deux ou trois lignes 18 on peut le dire
comme ça
peut-être et 2 être exagéré mais de
toute façon il y en aura qu'une
et puis il y aura peut-être pas du tout
puisque d'une part la ligne 18 et le
prévu pour 2024
mais c'est sur le papier dans la
pratique il y aura des retards
tous ces grands projets il ya des
retards c'est ce que on va en parler
justement vous vous faites sûrement
référence à tout ce que l'on entend
depuis cet été depuis l'élection de
d'emmanuel macro que le grand paris
express pourrait voir certains de ces
chantiers retarder voire peut être
annulé 1 ce qui se tourne a même sans ça
rien que pour un projet de cette année
là les statistiques montrent les presser
l'expérience montre que le dépassement
moyen c'est du genre 45%
mais le fait qu'ils aient paris 2025 les
jeux 2024 ça pourrait pour cette fois ci
en tout cas assuré un temps respecter on
peut envisager que il y aura vraiment de
pour 2024
la ligne 18 me soit répondre aux enjeux
c'est une belle théorie mais après il ya
la contrainte physique et logique qui
est logique après l'été aux blindes
audience hier s'il faut assurer au nord
de paris
parce que c'est là qu'ils alhaji
oppressé particulier à saint quentin en
yvelines
il dit souvent non non le cyclisme sur
piste n'est pas accessoire
non mais là c'est sûr l'ensemble c'est
vrai c'est un peu du coup sûr sur cette
ligne 18 je voulais je voulais en parler
puisque vous êtes membre de
l'association des usagers des transports
vous vous êtes un contre cette ligne 18
plutôt olé dire contre vous voulez son
abandon vous dites aujourd'hui c'est pas
là la priorité elle est surdimensionné
il faudrait peut-être mettre les fonds
de cette ligne 18 / sur le réseau
existant pour pour l'améliorer c'est ce
que dit la hutte et oui et puis le
deuxième argument dans ce domaine a
c'est que on n'a pas les moyens de faire
à la fois
la rénovation du réseau existant et
nouveau réseau a coûté et qui dont
l'utilité est plutôt marginal là vous
partez vous parlez de la ligne 18 vous
visez pas toutes les lignes ça fait
partie du grand paris express
donc le grand paris express commence par
la ligne 15 qui est en voie de
construction et après il ya les autres
lignes de la ligne 18 c'est à peu près
la dernière ce serait la dernière en
terme de temps en tout cas pour aller
jusqu'à versailles 2030
est-ce que c'est pas un peu paradoxal de
voir ce territoire paris saclay qui ne
cesse de se développer qui va continuer
à se développer forcément vous le disiez
des gens qui vont venir vous disiez vous
même beaucoup de gens qui vont venir et
dire en même temps on construit pas de
nouvelles lignes
il ya quand même une difficulté c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que l'état s'est
créé un problème de cadrature du cercle
tout seul en mettant toutes les grandes
écoles les unes à côté des autres
avec l université puis avec les
commerces et des habitations et tout le
tralala sont sans qu'il y ait maintenant
que le projet n'en sait ce qu'il peut
pas se dire allez la ligne 18 elle
arriverait dans deezer enfin 2024
théoriquement mais plus pratiquement n'y
croyez pas décidément 2024 allons
c'est quasiment impossible
déjà la ligne 15 elle a pris du retard
dès le départ de deux ans et on sait
qu'il ya encore de nouveaux retards qui
ont été eux que l'on connaît mais qui
n'ont pas encore été avoué ça ne savent
à décaler tout le reste
alors il y aura des annonces qui seront
sûrement faite par le président de la
république en prêt en janvier
je voulais aussi avoir votre réflexion
sur les problèmes actuels du réseau
francilien on le sait tous les
transports en commun des retards tous
les jours des problèmes très importants
des dysfonctionnements très récemment à
paris montparnasse qui s'étale sur sur
plusieurs jours est ce que justement
c'est pas là une preuve que le réseau
semble aujourd'hui saturé ne plus
marcher ce qu'il faudrait pas ce nouveau
réseau qui pourrait alléger en termes de
voyageurs le réseau actuel
mais est-ce que vous l'état sait qu'il
faudra attendre encore quinze ans pour
que le nouveau réseau remplacé vers 6
pts et que pendant quinze ans ça va être
très difficile
en réalité on peut pas faire seulement
le nouveau réseau aux pumas trait de
côte et l'ancien il faut commencer par
rénover le réseau existant ne fût ce que
pour accueillir dans des conditions
décentes les
liu et je ne parle pas de l'expo
universelle qui est hypothétique
mais les yo c'est une certitude donc et
puis la date n'est pas négociable
donc il va falloir mettre enfin rénové
dare dare le réseau existant que c'est
possible aujourd'hui de faire mieux avec
le réseau actuel parfois un peu
l'impression qu'il est complètement
saturé que finalement les pouvoirs
publics ne peuvent plus faire grand
chose qu'il est à bout ce réseau est
finalement on peut le rénover mais on
est il faut y mettre les moyens toujours
plus de voyageurs toujours plus de
déplacements est ce qu'on peut répondre
à ça avec le réseau qui lui forcément ne
grandit pas il n'est pas extensible
comme le nombre de voyageurs là on
connaît les cons et les chiffres il
faudrait il consulté les études du
cercle des transports qui montre que le
réseau s'il fonctionnait bien ne serait
pas saturé on a les capacités de
répondre à la demande a été plus il ya
des capacités l'augmentation enfin des
augmentations de capacité potentielle
augmentation de capacité
par exemple en mettant des rames à deux
niveaux sur la rb c'est ce que va
commencer à faire là la région ile de
france est aussi l'art sur du long terme
signés mais pour l'instant on parle 2028
on parle de deux projets pour les
usagers c'est totalement inacceptable
cet horizon là je vais donner quelques
chiffres pour cerner vraiment l'enjeu
des transports en commun en
ile-de-france quelques chiffres 1500 km
de voies ferroviaires sur la région
ile-de-france 1,5 milliard d'euros de
budget par an et 41 millions de
déplacements par jour je dis pas de
voyageurs je parle de déplacement
comment puisqu'on parlait de la région
et de france de ses trains à deux étages
pour le rer b comment vous jugez la
politique des transports de valérie
pécresse qui peut avoir des défauts des
qualités
peu importe le bord politique à auquel
on appartient mais qui est très engagée
sur cette thématique des transports et
qui promet par exemple pour 2021 c'est
assez court 708 rames rénovées ou une
nouvelle comment vous jugez cette
politique vous ça c'est pas elle qui a
fait 1 ces rames étaient déjà commandé
par l'air
la région précédente elle dit qu'elle
tiendra les les engagements ce qui vous
l'aviez dit vous aussi au début de
l'émission n'est pas toujours le cas
oui bon tout ça c'est très bien on ne
peut pas bien mais on peut pas être
contre mais le problème c'est que la
région n'est la compétence que pour les
transports
elle n'a aucun on n'a rien à dire sur
l'aménagement du territoire et on peut
pas dissocier c2c de l'industrie au jeu
là ce sont les traitements étroitement
liées entre elles vous dites que entre
les collectivités il ya trop de on sait
pas qui fait quoi il faudrait clarifier
ça on a en ile de france on a on a deux
problèmes
on a un problème de logement on a un
problème de transport et on ne peut
résoudre ces deux problèmes
conjointement du reste que en réformant
les la gouvernance de la région
c'est un vaste problème on aura
peut-être l'occasion de l'évoquer une
prochaine fois je voulais juste vous
faire réagir maintenant sur sur la
hausse très rapidement du passe navigo
elle est très probable même si elle est
patent pas encore officiel pour l'année
prochaine vous la région dit qu'une
hausse du passe navigo est nécessaire
pour financer justement ces
investissements vous vous répondez quoi
vous nous on a toujours été nous c'est à
dire à la fois des associations du
plateau que la hutte et on peut jurer
était très opposé
on passe navigo unique
ça part d'un bon sentiment pour pour les
classes pour les gens ne vous éloignez
skull et mullie mais la conséquence est
que vous favoriser l'étalement urbain
vous a encouragé les gens à s'établir
plus loin parce que c'est comme ça que
ça fonctionne dans la pratique les gens
se donnent un budget comme on dit un
budget de temps de déplacement et ce
budget là il est constant il est de 1h30
grosso modo par jour en moyenne pour le
francilien moyens et ça c'est comme ça
depuis 40 ans et donc si vous mettez des
lignes à grande vitesse du genre grand
paris express
la conséquence mécanique c'est que les
gens vont aller plus loin est ce qu'ils
se donnent une heure et demie par jour
encore mais on leur donne des liaisons
plus rapide
demain ils vont aller plus bas parce que
là ça coûte moins cher ils sont plus
proches de la nature
c'est ça le phénomène est et il ya
aucune aucune maîtrise de ces phénomènes
méditons c'est sur le long terme
armez vous restez avec nous on va faire
un tour complet maintenant du reste de
l'actualité locale de la semaine avec
notamment 7 problème des déplacements
mais à saint quentin en yvelines
elle était très attendue sur le
territoire annoncé depuis plusieurs mois
la vélostation aux faits a enfin ouvert
ce jeudi en gare de saint quentin en
yvelines trois services sont proposés
aux habitants et usagers un
stationnement sécurisé un service de
location de vélos ainsi qu'un atelier de
réparation et de maintenance les détails
avec ce sujet d'aurélie rose des vélos
qui attendent leurs futurs compagnons de
route
voici la vélostation de saint quentin en
yvelines après sept ans d'attentes les
saint quentinois bénéficie désormais
d'un espace pour leur deux roues 230 en
placements sont sécurisés
vous avez un lecteur de badge à
l'extérieur on passe le pass navigo et
donc la personne l'utilisateur rentre
son vélo et le stationnent sur les sur
les espaces qui sont prévus à cet
endroit
autre service proposé par la vélostation
la location de vélos il y en a cent
soixante dix ans tout compter 3 euros la
journée pour la location d'un vélo
standard 15 euros par jour pour un vélo
à assistance électrique
enfin un service de maintenance propose
de s'occuper de votre deux roues la
personne prend rendez vous nous
l'accueillons à l'atelier et nous
entretenons réparons le vélo suivant un
forfait près établi pièces et main
d'oeuvre pour des prestations qui vont
de la crevaison
la révision générale du vélo avec ses
400 km d'aménagements cyclables
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'inscrit dans
une démarche de mobilité durable
objectif avec cette vélostation
encourager les usagers de la gare à
utiliser ces transports propres
la part modale d'utilisateurs est encore
relativement peu élevé 2 % mais donc
avec ce ces nouvelles facilités à dessus
on espère d'affaires passer de 4 à 5%
donc au moins la doubler assez
prochainement
enfin sachez que se déplaçait à vélo est
bon pour l'environnement mais aussi du
bon pour la santé
une pratique quotidienne permettrait
d'allonger de cinq ans son espérance de
vie arme smith était en rapport avec le
sujet qu'on évoquait les déplacements là
il s'agit du vélo ce type d'action c'est
ce qu'il faut encourager développer
localement en tout cas absolument oui je
pense que ce dont on a besoin surtout
c'est de d'améliorer les liaisons
locales
à l'intérieur des bassins d'emploi
bassin de vie et le vélo fait partie
bien sûr toutes les appelle les
circulations douces les modes actifs
participe de ce phénomène
donc c'est toujours ça de pris mais bon
évidemment ça ne résout pas le gros du
problème ça ne résout pas le ca fait
c'est pas quel est le pourcentage à la
proportion de gens qui je crois aussi le
vélo 12 % des déplacements aujourd'hui
en région parisienne donc même si ça
reste rsa monte à 10 % c'est bien mais
ça résout pas le problème
donc je pense qu'il faut d'autres moyens
de transport il est le problème
lesquels par exemple très rapidement
lorsque c'est le problème auquel les
transports ou de faire cesser la
desserte des zones périurbaines
c'est là qu'on est et pour ce post pour
c il n'y a pas de clientèle pour se
payer des moyens lourds
donc il faut des trouver des moyens plus
léger dans ce domaine là contre la
promotion d'une solution qui s'appelle
carmina qui était en cours de
développement et qui est 100 fois moins
cher qu'un métro carlina c'est un
tramway du coup c'est quoi ces cds petit
véhicule à quatre personnes qui se
déplacent indépendamment d'accor donc ce
serait des transports en commun en
autonome ça n'a rien à voir avec ça si
c'est mais ce sont ces cdu voiture
guidée des guides et d'action trajet
défini et pas sur les routes c'est au
dessus de la route trois ou quatre
mètres au dessus de la route
jean un transport en commun presque
volant comme dans les films de science
fiction ça pourrait devenir réalité
c'est pas volant ça non mais bien sûr
j'imagine que ça vole pas mais c'est
pour l'équipe ça va dans des rails dans
des petits rats y est
donc c'est très léger c'est même presque
rustique mais ça comme ça c'est 100 fois
moins cher ça ouvre des horizons pour la
desserte et les zones périurbaines merci
armes smit d'être venu en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes membre de
plusieurs associations notamment le
collectif au yen saclay et aussi
l'association des usagers des transports
merci à vous et bon week end je vous en
prie un salon de coiffure solidaire a
ouvert ses portes elle en cours chez
agora tiff les personnes en difficultés
financières peuvent s'offrir les
services d'une coiffeuse professionnelle
pour moins de 10 euros
le lieu fait déjà un carton plein de
trois semaines après son arrivée dans la
commune
reportages découvertes avec aurélie
ronze et camille lambert shampoing coupe
brushing et coloration tous les services
d'un salon de coiffure traditionnelle à
un détail près ici les tarifs sont
adaptés aux plus démunis de 3 à 8 euros
maximum un salon de coiffure solidaire
pour retrouver confiance en soi entre
les mains bénévoles de nathalie c'est
important de se regarder dans un miroir
et de ne pas se déclarent de se dire
tiens aujourd'hui j'ai une bonne mine
j'ai une bonne tête je vais aller vers
les autres parce que je me vois bien
tout à l'heure la dame j'ai fait un
petit massage aller contente parce que
c'est pas des choses qu'on a l'habitude
d'avoir rendre la coiffure et l'estiment
de soit accessible quel que soit son
revenu
c'était le pari de la mairie d'elancourt
installé dans le centre social l'agora
ce nouveau salon a été inauguré le 8
décembre en présence du maire jean
michel fourgous et de son adjointe
martine letoublon à l'initiative du
projet les personnes qui viennent dans
ce salon réunit enfin essentiellement
des personnes qui sont à la recherche
d'un emploi qui ont un entretien
d'embauché parce qu'on est là vraiment
pour leur tendre la main pour les
réinsérer dans la vie professionnelle
il ya aussi les personnes qui sont
handicapés qui ont dit faible revenu les
personnes
on oublie souvent les personnes âgées
qui se retrouve avec le minimum
vieillesse qui ne peuvent pas aller chez
le coiffeur
le salon est ouvert les mercredis matin
sur rendez-vous seules obligations
demandées par nathalie repartir avec le
sourire
des sourires justement et du rire c'est
habituel de les voir sur le visage des
enfants ils se font pourtant plus rares
pour ceux qui sont malades est habitué à
l'hôpital pour tenter d'égayer leur
quotidien l'association rire 78 propose
des spectacles directement à l'hôpital à
l'hôpital andré mignot justement du
chéné l'une de ces animations avaient
lieu cette semaine c'était déjà noël
nicolas à kirillovitch et clés à
vancouver avec un spectacle et quelques
sourires c'est fou ce que l'on peut
faire pour des enfants à l'hôpital
à quelques jours de noël en guise de
cadeau avant l'heure une centaine
d'entre eux a pu profiter d'une
animation à l'hôpital du chesnay
histoire de délaisser soucis et problème
l'espace de quelques instants
c'est pour les petits
sortir du quotidien médical vraiment en
fait côté festif plutôt que côté maladie
l'objectif c'est de prendre un petit peu
la vie plus sereine meilleur à tous ces
gens qui ont eu un pépin encore si vous
voulez et pour faire sourire ses enfants
à l'hôpital parce qu'à la cie auteur
compositeur habitué des performances
pour les plus jeunes propose un
spectacle tout en musique et en chanson
beds and avec on peut faire des gares et
des 10 6
ceci un spectacle comme un autre mais
parfois on est pris par surprise par
l'émotion parce qu'il va se dérouler un
événement inattendu différents proposés
par l'association rire 78 depuis dix ans
l'opération rire pour guérir est aussi
un temps pour le corps médical
un temps qui permet de créer un lien
différent et rassurant pour les enfants
de voir que les soignants peuvent
proposer un spectacle
e
de proposer eux
enfin de voir les soignants sourire et
rire et nous aussi de veut connaître les
parents et de voir les enfants sourire
et rire ça nous fait ça fait du bien à
tout le monde tous les ans rires 78
propose une dizaine de spectacles dans
les hôpitaux yvelinois des parenthèse
heureuse pour tenter de vaincre la
maladie est évidemment vous l'aurez
compris si je me suis cité c'était
totalement avant mon père en politique
sophie primas sénatrice des yvelines
intègre le nouvel organigramme des
républicains l'ancien maire
d'aubergenville a été nommée secrétaire
générale adjointe en charge des
relations avec les parlementaires
un choix de laurent wauquiez le nouveau
président du parti el lundi nous
interrogions d'ailleurs sophie primas
après la victoire du président de la
région rhône alpes elle appelait alors
au rassemblement écouter le résultat
était attendu et maintenant je crois qu
on a tous envie qu'il se passe quelque
chose on s'appelle tout le monde au
rassemblement où ça il ya beaucoup de
gens qui parlent du rassemblement qui
n'ont pas un seul échantillon sur eux
comme aurait dit coluche
donc maintenant je crois qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui a été élu il faut que dans
son comportement il appelle et donne des
signes du rassemblement et puis il faut
que les autres aussi et envie de
construire ait envie d'être rassemblés
c'est l'enjeu des trois prochains mois à
la fois donc au portement dans les
paroles dans les actes politiques
toujours et saint rémy les chevreuse qui
ne sera pas la première commune
francilienne en marche la liste sans
étiquette conduite par dominique bat boy
a gagné hier l'élection municipale
partielle c'était dimanche
elle devance de 22 voix la candidature
et les rues même de domi dominique
dufrasne l'autre liste sans étiquette de
jean louis binic et els 3e de ce second
tour à moins de cent voix du nouveau
maire dominique bad boy devrait donc
être désigné maire de saint rémy les
chevreuse lors du prochain conseil
municipal extraordinaire prévue mardi
les fêtes de fin d'année débute dans dix
jours seulement vous êtes peut-être en
panne d'inspiration pour faire des
cadeaux voici une idée que vous pourriez
su
gérée au père noël des créations aux
motifs africains à montigny le
bretonneux et self à cannes propose des
vêtements mais aussi des accessoires
réalisés à partir de tissus africains
fabriqués par des artistes du continent
reportage tell me lambert et aurélie
rose je vais vous montrer le vêtement
pas de la saison il fait froid mais on
essaie que c'est un dense et la mini
jupe qui est fait en wax au motif
qu'elle tait depuis un an estelle facam
a lancé sa marque dot et compagnie suite
à l'engouement du wax un tissus aux
motifs traditionnels africains très
tendance depuis ces dernières années et
qu'elle a souhaité mettre en avant dans
ses créations
autre objectif promouvoir un
savoir-faire africain comporte beaucoup
le box en afrique
mais en afrique il ya de vrais tissus
africains et la plupart des tissus
africains demandent vraiment un travail
d'artistes d'artisans parce que ce sont
des tissus tissé de fils de coton et
plus de teintes et à la main en tout les
motifs que nous voyons pour les dessins
gouffran sont réalisées à main levée
estelle fait venir directement ses
tissus de côte d'ivoire du sénégal et du
cameroun
c'est ensuite chez elle qu'elle les
transforme en jupe tuniques ou
accessoires
[Musique]
petit bandeau pris mes vêtements ne
s'adresse pas forcément aux connaisseurs
parce que voilà c'est surtout à ceux qui
sont curieux qui veulent découvrir
d'autres façons de s'habiller et surtout
à ceux qui veulent un peu sorti de
l'ordinaire et apporter une pièce
originale à l'heure à leur tenue de tous
les jours comptez 35 euros pour une du
portefeuille
une cinquantaine d'euros pour un sac
dans ses prochaines collections estelle
mettra également en valeur des motifs
indonésien péruvien et colombiens c'est
la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo avant de se
quitter je ne peux m'empêcher de saluer
pascal notre monteur qui part ce soir à
la retraite après plus de vingt ans de
bons et loyaux services au sein de tv 78
ou plutôt tv fil 78 pour lui merci
pascal pour tout ce travail accompli
c'était lui par exemple qui était ce
soir en charge du son pour cette
émission merci encore et puis plein de
bonnes choses dans cette nouvelle
aventure qui sera merveilleuse j'en suis
sûr l'information elle revient en direct
lundi à 18 heures d'ici là restez
informés grâce à notre site internet et
notre application tv 78 bon week-end à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]